We aim to facilitate and simplify shopping
Users in the entire travel market
Search for flights and hotels.
We deluded ourselves as an online market driven by research.
We launched our application for Andriod devices in early 2014
Since then, growth has been really rapid.
There is an active forum of developers
Are developing software for Android.
So it really makes it easier for our team to participate
Their experiences are also learning from other developers.
Moving to multidimensional design came as a natural step forward.
We wanted to provide a local language experience
More realistic users.
And provide a user interface they can simply understand
It is not taught to use specifically with the WEGO application
But to be used with every mobile application being installed.
Last year when we decided to redesign our entire application
Using the principles of multidimensional design, it was
The first thing we did was transfer to Andriod Studio
It took time to get used to it.
Then things went very smoothly
Thanks to the new libraries provided by Google.
We moved to the stylish designs of multidimensional
With bold colors and widescreen printing
To draw attention to the content.
Check the action button in the floating ad
We've made a lot of improvements to the app
The experience with the app made good and really fast.
Within two months,
The most important thing we are proud of is that
Our application ratings were almost
During less than a year, it improved to reach
Increasing your app ratings incrementally,
With also getting millions of new users
Of the best achieved in the industry.